foreign
welcome back to our Channel folks today
we have an exciting topic that often
Sparks debates in the world of tech AI
Engineers versus data scientist we will
dive deep into the roles
responsibilities and skills that set
these two professions apart so if you
are considering a career in artificial
intelligence or data science this video
is a must watch let's get started and
before that if you are one of the
aspiring python Enthusiast or Ai and ml
Enthusiast looking for online training
and graduating from the best
universities or a professional who are
decides to switch careers in python or
Ai and ml by learning from the experts
then try giving a show to Simply learns
postgraduate program in Ai and ml in
collaboration with Purdue University and
IBM the course link is mentioned in the
description box below that will navigate
to the course page where you can find a
complete overview of the program being
offered and don't forget to like
subscribe and share the video so
starting with first up let's talk about
AI engineers
so these Tech Wizards are The Architects
behind artificial intelligence systems
Engineers design and build the AI models
and systems that power everything from
self-driving cars to Virtual assistants
like CD or Alexa they are experts in
machine learning and deep learning
focusing on algorithms neural networks
and model optimization debugging fine
tuning and making these models
sufficient is a significant part of
their job
and now moving on to the roles for
artificial intelligence engineer that is
duties and responsibilities of
artificial intelligence Engineers so
artificial intelligence Engineers are
tasked with utilizing algorithms to
construct applications and systems that
enhance organizational efficiency reduce
operational expenses booster profits and
facilitate improved business decision
making
their primary focus is on Crafting
practical tools and solutions often
involving the training of algorithms
through data to enhance their
performance
below are some of the key duties and
responsibilities of artificial
intelligence Engineers that we'll
discuss now
starting with constructing models to
eight Business Leaders in decision
making and data analysis the next is
formulating strategies and identifying
problems in need of resolution then we
have establishing and overseeing digital
infrastructures that incorporate
artificial intelligence then we have
automating solutions to support the data
science team's efforts then we have
converting models into apis for seamless
integration with other applications and
the other duties or the responsibilities
are collaborating with colleagues and
facilitating knowledge sharing sessions
to promote technology adoption and the
dissemination of best practices
now moving on to roles of artificial
intelligence engineer
so companies hire artificial
intelligence Engineers the first role is
to automate repetitive task the second
is improve the accuracy of decisions
third is transform decision making into
a logical process without emotional
interferences or bias next we have is
perform risk analysis then we have
improved the efficiency and precision of
business operations then reduce
operational cost by downsizing employees
and now moving on to see the skills
required for artificial intelligence
Engineers so artificial intelligence
engineering is primarily a technical
role centered around working with
machine learning algorithms to excel in
this field and Forge a successful career
you should cultivate the following
skills number one
programming proficiency mastering common
programming languages such as python R
and C plus plus is essential Proficiency
in these languages empowers you to
construct and Implement artificial
intelligence models effectively then we
have big data Technologies dealing with
extensive data sets is a common aspect
of training AI models familiarity with
big data Technologies like Hadoop Apache
spark and more modb streamlines the
process of accessing and managing the
required data then we have mathematical
Acumen a solid grasp of advanced
mathematical Concepts including
statistics probability and linear
algebra is crucial these skills underpin
the design and implementation of various
machine learning algorithms then we have
algorithmic expertise successful AI
Engineers process a deep understanding
of machine learning algorithms such as
navbase linear regression generative
adversial networks and neural networks
this knowledge enables them to choose
and deploy the most appropriate
algorithms for specific tasks then we
have machine learning Frameworks
implementing AI models involves using
popular machine learning Frameworks like
pyrotech Cafe tensorflow and thano
Proficiency in these framework is
fundamental to building and fine-tuning
AI systems then comes the soft skills in
addition to technical provides
cultivating soft skills is invaluable
for advancing in the field of air
engineering these skills include
critical thinking problem solving
decision making emotional intelligence
creativity leadership and effective
communication developing these
attributes enhances your ability to
collaborate build professional
relationship and progress in your career
and before that if you are one of the
aspiring python enthusiastic Ai and ml
enthusiasts looking for online training
graduating from the best universities or
a professional who elicits to switch
careers in python or a and ml by
learning from the experts then try
giving a show to Simply learn skeltic Ai
and ml bootcamp the course link is
mentioned in the description box that
will navigate you to the course page
where you can find a complete overview
of the program being offered now moving
on to the data scientist so who is a
data scientist data scientists are
skilled in collecting processing and
analyzing large volumes of data to
extract valuable insights we use various
statistical and computational techniques
to identify patterns Trends and
correlations with data sets they
translate complex data into
understandable insights that guide
strategic choices optimize processes and
solve business problems
now moving on to see duties and
responsibilities of data scientists so
data scientists shoulder a range of
responsibilities in the day-to-day work
which can vary depending on the role and
specific projects some common duties
include data collection they identify
and gather data from various sources
ensuring its accuracy and relevance to
the business objectives then we have
data analysis data scientists analyze
both structured and unstructured data
often collaborating with the team to
device strategist for achieving business
goals then we have data strategy
development they create data driven
strategies and solutions to address
business challenges effectively and the
next responsibility or duty is inside
Discovery data scientists and called
Trends patents and insights hidden
within data sets providing actionable
information then the next responsibility
is data presentation using visualization
tools and techniques they present data
in a comprehensive manner to managers
and executives
then we have tool selection they
research and select the more suitable
tools for developing new analysis
strategies
and now moving on to roles of data
scientist
data scientists are an integral part of
many companies serving several key
functions so the number one is pattern
and Trend identification data scientists
are Adept at identifying patterns and
prints with business data they shift
through vast data sets to uncover
valuable insights the next is
statistical insights they provide
statistical insights that guide decision
making their ability to analyze data
statistically is pivotal in making
informed choices the next is exploratory
data analysis data scientists include
exploratory data analysis to gain a
deeper understanding of the information
at hand this helps in identifying
outliers correlations and potential
areas of interest and then we have
predictive analysis one of their
essential tasks is implementing
predictive analysis models by leveraging
data they can forecast future Trends and
outcomes now moving on to skills
required for data scientists to excel in
this role data scientists need a blend
of Technical and soft skills these
skills enable them to work effectively
with data and collaborate with teams
number one is Big Data Technologies
Proficiency in tools like Peg Hive
Cassandra and Hadoop for managing and
analyzing large data sets next is
programming languages mystery of
languages such as R python Ruby C plus
plus PHP and Matlab for data
manipulation and Analysis then we have
big data management tools knowledge of
tools like SQL and teradata for
efficient data management
then business intelligence tools
familiarity with tools like Tableau for
data visualization and Reporting then we
have statistical techniques expertise in
statistical methods like regression
principle concept analysis and
clustering and then we have soft skills
and now moving on to the key differences
so that we set these two roles apart
so starting with the number one
difference that is focus so AI Engineers
focus on developing AI models and
deploying them into applications while
data scientists concentrate on exploring
data to generate actionable insights
however there's an overlap both need a
strong foundation in programming
languages like Python and are
comfortable with tools like tensorflow
and pytorch the second difference is
education and skills let's talk about
them so AI Engineers often have degrees
in computer science AI or related fields
while data scientists may have
backgrounds in mathematics statistics or
computer science number three we have a
skills so for AI Engineers a deep
understanding of algorithms and model
architecture is crucial whereas for data
scientists data scientists should excel
in data manipulation statistics and
domain knowledge and now moving on to
the next difference that is earning
prospects so AI Engineers are in high
demand as companies raised to implement
AI Solutions and the average annual
salary of artificial intelligence
engineer in India is 11 lakhs per year
while in us it's 160 000 per annum and
if you talk about data scientists the
average annual salary of data scientists
in India is 13 lakhs per year while in
U.S it's 152 000 per annum
and now moving on to the next difference
that is applications
so types of data products that a data
scientist builds include recommender
systems flow detection systems customize
Healthcare recommendations whereas the
types of application that an artificial
intelligence engineer builds include
Voice Assistant intelligent humanoid
robots self-driving cars chatbots and
more the next difference is tools so
Apache Hadoop Apache spark python R sus
spwsw
Etc these are the tools that an
artificial intelligence engineer have
hands on whereas for a data scientist
the tools are Apache mahout Keras
tensorflow scikit-learn Shogun Cafe Pi
torch
so these were the tools and we have
ended with the differences between AI
engineer and the data scientist
so now comes the question which should
you choose so choosing between a career
as a data scientist or an AI engineer is
a decision that ultimately depends on
your interest and skill set both
professions offer a promising future
with a strong job outlook and high
salary potential it's important to note
that advanced education such as master
degree can provide a Competitive Edge
and increase your marketability in these
fields
so you can consider joining the simply
learns program for your master's degree
so thanks for tuning in don't forget to
like share and subscribe for more
exciting Tech discussions and remember
when you choose a engineering or data
science you are contributing to The
Incredible World of artificial
intelligence
so well there you have it folks we hope
you enjoyed this adventure and with that
let's take a minute to hear from our
Learners who have experienced massive
success in their careers
you need to keep updating your skills
the course material was comprehensive
and the faculty was extremely
experienced The Faculty was able to
adjust their teaching style in order to
cater to the overall skill set of the
class in the rapidly evolving world of
technology it's important to keep up
Skilling for every working professional
stay relevant continue learning and if
you like this session then like share
and subscribe if you have any questions
then you can drop them in the comment
section below thanks for watching and
stay tuned for more from Simply learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here